OMG LOL WUT EMOJI EMOJI EMOJI OMG!
JUST SAY IT!
Message from Trace Dominguez, everyone!
Thanks for swiping right on DNews.
According to the Pew Research Center on Internet,
Science and Tech -- only 35 percent of Americans
texted at ALL in 2006.
Then in 2015 Pew reported, 100 percent of
18-29 year olds text, duh.
But 92% of people over 50 also text!
That's a lot of people doing something that
didn't even exist a little over ten years
ago.
It took 80 years -- from 1900 to 1980 -- for
cars to get anywhere close to those numbers…
So, when something like this takes over so
quickly, scientists have to struggle to catch
up to how it's affecting us!
For example, a new study in Epilepsy & Behavior
found that when some people text (either on
a phone or a tablet) a whole new brainwave
appears.
In fact, the researchers said they'd never
seen anything like this; this brainwave is
unique!
When a brainwave changes, it's usually because
the brain activity is changing.
Think of it like the flashing light on your
computer.
Different patterns can show different things,
and this one is new!
The researchers aren't exactly sure what this
new wave means, but they think it shows the
brain is using emotion, attention, motor-skills,
and auditory-verbal activity all together.
Funnily enough, this only shows up when texting
on smaller screens.
Indicating, yet again, quote, "people shouldn't
text and drive," because texting changes how
the brain is functioning.
And some of those changes are for the better!
For example, in 2009 a study in Bioelectromagnetics
found kids who texted had faster response
times on computer tests, but were less accurate
in their responses.
In fact, kids who used mobile phones (in general)
had poorer working memory, but had faster
learnings for simple and associative memory
tasks! and another small study from a 2011
British Journal of Psychology argues that
kids who use abbreviations while texting tend
to use fewer as they get older and more educated,
and their spelling scores are better those
who didn't text at all.
Yet another study says that "skilled texting"
also leads to better spelling.
There's even a really weird study that shows
our brains are forming stronger connections
to our thumbs because of texting.
According to their results, in Cell, smartphone
users who text had more sensitive touch on
the end of their thumb than people who didn't
-- more phone use, better perception.
So strange.
But of course, there are also negatives.
Multitasking isn't real.
Our brains, cannot multitask, we can only
serial task.
We can pause this main thing, and then do
-- [SENDS TEXT] -- then come back to it.
But that back and forth takes a LOT more effort
than just finishing the first task.
You might be arguing with me in the comments
already, but that's because you're probably
overconfident, sensation-seeking, and impulsive.
People.
MULTITASKING ISN'T A THING.
In fact, Neuroscientist Daniel J. Levitin
writes even trying to multitask increases
the stress hormone cortisol and releases adrenaline,
causing scrambled thinking and mental fog
after a while.
This happens because your prefrontal cortex
has to stop what it's doing, burn some energy
to save your spot, and pick up a second task.
It can do this quickly, which is why you think
you're doing it simultaneously, but you're
not.
Plus, you have to decide to answer a text,
causing decision-fatigue.
AND a study in Computers and Human Behavior
found people who think they can multitask
spend more time studying (to make up for that
switching cost) and do poorer in school overall.
Texting is changing how our brains work, how
we interact with our own bodies, each other,
our environment, and how we learn and see
the world.
It's a massively influential tool.
But, like any tool, learning how and when
you use it -- is probably more import… [beep]
hang on i just have to answer this.
[[texting]] What was I saying?
Guys, I am not cool.
So, can someone tell me what's up with sex
texting.
Is that what they call it?
Sex-exting?
Don't worry, Dr. Ali Mattu knows what I mean
-- and we wanted to know if sexting can improve
your relationship!
If you're worried about being bothered by
texts, I have a solution!
Turn on your airplane mode when you're working
or studying.
It works!!
What do you think?
Do you have an out-of-contact strategy?